there's a trend there's a there's a  difference between being a troll because  it works the business model troll is  very effective yeah it's a very very  effective business model to accelerate  uh getting eyeballs look at what Andrew  Tate did he got under people's skins and  Bone the most viral man on the internet  no one's getting more eyeballs and the  guy does an interview Boom everybody  wants to know what this guy's got to say  but there there's a thing line like  Conor McGregor was a very good smack  talker until he lost the fight to Dustin  podian says hey tell your wife to stay  out of my DMs and then boom he crossed  the line there when you're talking about  trolling there's a line for trolling you  don't cross